we're told let G be a differentiable
function defined over the closed
interval from negative 4 to 4 the graph
of G is given right over here given
below
how many inflection points does the
graph of G have and so let's just remind
ourselves what our inflection points so
inflection points are where we change
concavity so we go from concave concave
upwards upwards actually let me just
draw it graphically we're going from
concave upwards to concave downwards or
concave downwards to concave upwards so
or another way you could think about it
you could say we're going from our slope
increasing increasing increasing to our
slope decreasing to our slope decreasing
or the other way around any points where
your slope goes from decreasing our
slope goes from decreasing to increasing
to increasing so let's think about that
so as we start off right over here so we
at the extreme left it seems like we
have a very high slope it's a very steep
curve and then it stays increasing but
it's getting less positive so it's
getting a little bit it's getting a
little bit flatter so our slope is at a
very high level but it's decreasing it's
decreasing decreasing decreasing slope
is decreasing decreasing even more it's
even more and then it's actually going
to zero our slope is zero and then it
becomes negative so our slope is still
decreasing as then it's becoming more
and more and more negative and then
right around and then right around here
it looks like it starts becoming less
negative or it starts increasing so our
slope is increasing increasing it's
really just becoming less and less
negative and then it's be going close to
zero approaching zero it looks like our
slope is zero right over here but then
it looks like right over there our slope
begins decreasing again so it looks like
our slope is decreasing again
so it looks like our slope is decreasing
becoming more and more and more and more
negative and so looks like something
interesting happened right over there we
had a transition point and then right
around here it looks like it starts the
slope starts increasing again so it
looks like the slope starts increasing
it's negative we cut but it's becoming
less and less and less negative and then
it becomes 0 and then it becomes
positive and then more and more and more
and more positive so inflection points
are where we go from slope increasing to
slope decreasing so concave upwards to
concave downwards and so slope
increasing was here the slope decreasing
so this was an inflection point and also
from slope decreasing the slope
increasing so that's slope decreasing
the slope increasing and this is also
slope decreasing to slope increasing so
how many inflection points does the
graph of G have that we can see that we
on this graph well it has it has three
over the interval that at least week we
can see